hey guys and welcome back to the channel
if you're new here my name is dami and i
am an architect in beautiful vancouver
bc today we're going to be doing
something a little bit different we are
going to be looking at a couple of my
favorite sci-fi movies that have really
interesting architectural concepts
this video is sponsored by hp we'll talk
about my keyboard setup later in this
video
so the very first movie that we're
watching is x machina which is a great
movie if you guys haven't watched it
and the story line is about this is a
software engineer he wins a lottery to
do an experiment at the house of this
his ceo of his company whose cross
between jeff bezos and elon musk and
steve jobs and he created this ai this
android and the main character is
basically going to his house to perform
the modern version of a turing test to
see if this ai
can pass as a human everything takes
place in one house we'll kind of go over
the house in a little bit but it's a
really fascinating movie if you haven't
watched it so he arrives at this very
foreign landscape
he's already kind of thrown in this very
ambiguous situation
he's like just go down the path and he's
like where's the path
i like how it transitions from super
super super loud and hectic to
silent
the house is very discreet it's kind of
hidden in the bushes
very mysterious
and this is actually a real building by
the way it's a hotel in norway yeah the
entire movie is shot inside this hotel
the house itself almost becomes a
character his first encounter with the
ceo is actually his house the house says
a lot about the person actually this
cladding if i'm not mistaken is a pine
treated pine cladding um peter zumther
actually uses this in his home and
office the color of the cladding i think
adds to the
dark tone you know it's not the
light wood color
and you have this incredibly heavy metal
door the door is the connection between
the outside and inside and i think the
weight of the door has a really big
impact on how you perceive the space
when you go inside and so it's already
creating this like sense of mystery this
detail is really nice here where the
glass meets the stone the original
architect of the real building said they
really really try to focus on minimal
intervention to the site and that's
their approach to sustainability this
detail really speaks to that philosophy
they're saying no we're not going to
touch the existing site we're going to
transform our building cut the glass to
meet all the jaggedy edges of the
existing stone and you can see this
detail in falling water by frank lloyd
wright as well which is probably one of
the most iconic integration of
architecture into nature
floor-to-ceiling glass everywhere
i think there's a really clever use of
glass in this entire movie you've never
been outside this building
no
you've never walked outside
i've never been outside the room i've
been known it really
confuses you sometimes it's almost
impossible to tell who's the subject of
the experiment and who is the
experimenter and it also talks about a
contrast between
confinement and freedom the scene is
interesting too because i think this
tree
has something very symbolic to this
movie when you're downstairs in the
basement you have this very manicured
landscape this little hot with these two
little trees and upstairs you have this
expansive nature all around you like if
you compare the use of glass upstairs to
downstairs
upstairs the glass is used to
enclose the space but at the same time
provide views to this expansive forest
and to this lake and you can look out
into the mountains
and then downstairs the glass is used to
confine you actually the original
building
has frosted glass throughout
and i think they use cgi to make it
transparent or
maybe they created a new set for this in
the real building they're using the
frosted glass to create a create privacy
and create a sense of relaxation and
calmness by turning all of the glass
transparent you're able to see
everything so it's creating an
environment of surveillance
five years ago building on the research
of our predecessors at the institute
my team and i discovered a process by
which all organic material can be
reduced at the cellular level
by a ratio of approximately two thousand
seven hundred forty four to one
downsizing is a sci-fi comedy drama
and it's a movie that i like very much
although it got pretty bad reviews on
rotten tomatoes i think it's really
funny and smart so a group of scientists
invent this method where you shrink the
human body into something about five
inches and this was their solution to
climate change and overpopulation well
by downsizing you consume less material
and you in turn help the earth
i hold here in my hand
all of the uncomposable waste produced
by 36 people over four years
the story is about paul matt damon who
you know in his dire hours kind of going
through a mid-life crisis decides to go
through this procedure and it's
non-reversible one of the benefits of
downsizing of course is that you can
take your savings and
when you apply that to your downsized
life your money because everything is so
small becomes like millions and millions
of dollars and so you can live this very
very lavish life in this tiny community
and so paul
he decides to go through this procedure
with his wife
but when he actually shrinks himself he
ends up alone because his wife ends up
ditching him last minute i thought this
movie was really interesting because
it's focusing inwards not outwards like
whenever we talk about the climate
crisis or overpopulation we're trying to
change a bunch of things in our
environment we're trying to build denser
we're trying to build faster to house
more people
but i really wonder what that process
was like for them to start researching
okay like none of these solutions are
working we have to like drastically
change something about ourselves this
really reminded me of this book that i
read called learning to die in the
anthropocene in this book the author
who's a war veteran he
lists elle in detail all the problems
that we have and he lists out in detail
all the solutions that we've created so
renewable energy solar geothermal
and he outlines why none of these
solutions are ever going to work and we
are basically screwed unless we
drastically change the way we live and
the way we think and philosophically
like die as civilizations and as
individuals and in this case the that
drastic change was
their physical change they shrunk their
size what's more interesting and more
ironic is that they've basically
combined the most sustainable solution
with the most unsustainable form of
urban development urban sprawl all of
these houses are you know the american
dream mansions and they're these massive
gated communities and they basically
shrunk themselves so that they can
consume as little as possible so that
they can live the lavish lifestyle that
they've always wanted to live in the end
they're not really changing anything
about themselves they're just changing
their size yeah it's kind of ironic and
kind of messed up because the first part
of the movie is them like contemplating
whether they should go through the
procedure or not and do you understand
that there exists an approximately 1 in
225 thousand chance that the procedure
could result
in injury permanent disability or death
when you look at
modern developments and
ideas of healthier living and healthier
cities it's denser like denser
communities where everything is walkable
and everything is bikeable but it really
makes you think if you had all the money
in the world and if you had millions and
millions of dollars to spend would we
still be trying to build these dense
societies or will we just be sprawling
out everywhere
as an architect and a youtuber i type a
lot and i mean a lot having a good
typing experience is really important to
me and the new hp 975 dual mode wireless
keyboard is really giving me a pretty
premium typing experience it's a
wireless keyboard with backlighting
which i consider absolutely essential
for typing in different light conditions
and you can connect up to three devices
at the same time all you need to do is
press the dedicated button to switch
between all your peripherals seamlessly
the keys are quiet and comfortable and i
really love that the keyboard has a full
size number pad on the right side which
makes it so much easier when you're
doing calculations or working with
spreadsheets the keyboard can detect
when your hands are coming closer to the
keys and turns on the backlight and the
battery can last weeks without a single
charge if you need more customization
you can use the hpac app to custom
assign more than 20 keys on your
personal needs this keyboard is made
with recycled plastic and packaged with
100 recycled paper as a part of hp's
commitment to producing sustainable
products follow the link in the
description if you want to learn more
about this keyboard
so the next one is a japanese science
fiction manga made by tsutomu nihei
who was actually trained in architecture
he actually went to parson design school
in new york but after working in
construction for a little bit he decided
to leave architecture and become a manga
artist so netflix recently made a movie
adaptation of the manga but i'm not
gonna talk about that i'm gonna focus
more on the manga itself because i feel
like the movie adaptation wasn't really
respectful to the original work so his
background in architecture is really
really really obvious in his manga
there's very little dialogue and you
really just understand the story looking
through the different environments that
he creates so the entire manga is this
character kili who we have very very
little background on and he says very
little and it's just him just wandering
and wandering and wandering through the
city which is constantly expanding so
they're trying to find this net terminal
gene and they're just trying to get away
from the city's defenses which is these
robots and silicones trying to attack
them so all these images make you feel
very small and lost and it's really vast
in scale and you can see that he took a
lot of inspiration from brutalist
architecture you know which is designed
with that intent it's designed with the
idea that communal is more important
than the individual so the timeline of
his career is that he was in
architecture school and then he did
construction for a very little time and
then he decided to become a manga artist
actually the skills that you learn in
architecture school i feel is closer to
being a manga artist
or animation than actual construction
we learn all these graphic tools to
represent spaces
and
it's really
apparent that he has an architectural
background because that's how you
represent your projects you represent
them through spaces not through people
or dialogue i think the interesting is
that when you're designing in school
you're designing spaces for people not
spaces that are hostile for people i
think his perspective is really unique
not just in the stylistic way he creates
his work but also in the storyline that
he creates because i think a lot of
architects they design buildings they
don't necessarily design the buildings
through the person's eyes so as a manga
artist i feel like you're working with a
lot of emotions with architecture we're
really working in the realm of beauty
and proportion and we really try to
bring in emotion into our
spaces or images although we should and
i think even though there's very little
dialogue and very little character
development that is the one point of
connection that you feel with the
characters the feeling of like being
lost and alone in the space as you're
flipping through these images
[Music]
i think it's really interesting that he
borrowed so much from brutalism and i
think if architecture was to become
alive brutalist architecture would be
the type that would want to destroy
humans it's the most foreboding
and dominant style of building and i
think it's really fitting that he used
this in a storyline
so elysium is about a dystopian society
based in in the future around 2154 it's
by a south african director that
actually has a huge influence on the
movie and i think he's trying to
recreate this society in south africa
where they
see these huge divides between rich and
poor i think the movie has an
opportunity to be a real social
commentary but i think what's more
interesting about the movie is the
realism of the environment that he
creates the entire world has become a
third world yeah so all these housing
it's very organic development it's very
similar to favelas favelas are informal
developments basically there's no rules
and it was just built purely out of
necessity by the inhabitants living
there here like this is favelas at a
massive scale yeah you can also see like
little houses on top of buildings
and that's actually what's happening in
places like hong kong like
they have these rooftop slums and
thousands of people are living in them
because they just don't have enough
space and then elysium is a satellite
community like a literal satellite
community that's orbiting around the
earth and all the rich people who could
afford to move there and it's in the
shape of a circle but it's very finite
it's kind of like saying
we can only fit in
a certain amount of people here and you
can see that a lot of the structures
that you see
in elysium are more fluid and organic
they tried to make this elysium really
realistic as possible and really tried
to think about the construction that
went behind it
and you can see that
a lot of these are in modules
and
a lot of the panels are in sizes that
are you know realistic enough that you
can transport them from earth to space
you know modular construction is the
future once we start fine-tuning
pre-fabrication and the ability to
design and fabricate things off-site and
bring them on site just to be assembled
that's gonna make construction so much
more efficient it's gonna cut errors
it's going to cut costs
we're going to be able to save so much
materials and labor
we just need a couple more years to get
there in this scenario like in space
you kind of have to do modular
construction like you
can't really have any room for errors
this kind of necessitates this modular
construction so there's a really
interesting book called refabricating
architecture by stephen kieran from
kieran timberlake he compares
architecture to industries like car
manufacturing or aerospace manufacturing
he looks at how efficient those
manufacturing systems are and by
adopting those methodologies we can
really really really improve a lot of
the processes like not just in
construction but all the way from design
to processing to manufacturing to the
operation of the building
[Music]
i need a new architect
so inception is a story about this thief
whose job is to go into the dreams of
these ceos and steal corporate secrets
the architect in this case is really
important because they designed the
environments for these dreams
to make the dreamer believe that it's
their dream now imagine you're designing
a building right you consciously create
each aspect but sometimes it feels like
it's almost creating itself if you know
what i mean yeah like i'm
discovering it genuine inspiration right
a lot of the things that they're saying
is really accurate to the process of
design a lot of the times when you start
designing you don't really know what
it's gonna look like
and so as you go through these different
options and through different sketches
and models you'll see what works and
what doesn't work and you'll see where
the design wants to go so it's really
like a process of discovery
i guess i thought that
the dream space would be all about the
visual but it's more about the feel of
it
i'm not lying on my carpet in my
apartment
a dream is not about visuals it's really
more about the sensation and i really
appreciate that they added this little
detail in here because i feel like that
would be something that would be really
difficult to convey in a movie because a
movie is a very visual experience when
you dream it really is more about a
feeling actually the other day i just
had a dream where i was at my old high
school but the surrounding was a beach
and there was a winding path to the high
school and beyond the beach like i could
see this beautiful sunset and there was
a cliff and it wasn't really any of the
details of the school it was just the
sensation and so in your waking life
this is very different because it's much
more focused on our visual senses it's
not really a recent phenomena but i feel
like as we spend more time on our phones
and our screens we do spend much much
much more time in the 2d it's much more
of a visual experience rather than a
sensory experience and this actually
leads to what we call experiential
impoverishment i actually talk about
this in my other video i'll leave the
link right here when we dream
our brains are much much much more
active and it's able to perceive things
more holistically it can perceive things
with smell sight touch taste and i think
that's why we're able to recreate these
environments so much faster than when
we're drawing in real life in
architecture it's actually called haptic
architecture it's when you incorporate
all of these different senses into your
spatial experience you know we should
really all be designing for all of these
senses but when you design for your
haptics not just your visuals
it makes your experience of the space
and your memory of the space much much
stronger and it really solidifies that
space in your mind
[Music]
i'm sure there's tons of other good
movies with great architectural concepts
if you have any suggestions let me know
in the comments and i think i'll
definitely try to make a part two of
these videos because i had a lot of fun
if you're interested in learning more
about architecture i'll leave a playlist
of my personal favorites right here i
also have a monthly newsletter where i
share my insights and things that i'm
learning or reading or listening to
as well as a discord channel where you
can chat with other people in this
amazing community and if you want to
support the channel and listen in on
interviews by me with other industry
professionals as well as access to other
perks i do have membership tiers that
you can join i'm gonna leave links to
all of this in the description of this
video and with that i'll see you in the
next one
[Music]
you